it's not every day a demon king bent on
world domination becomes everyone's
favorite grumpy uncle but Dragon Ball's
Piccolo isn't your everyday kind of
villain for many American Dragon Ball
fans English language dub actor
Christopher sabot is synonymous with the
character Piccolo although thanks to
streaming services simulcasting Dragon
Ball super during its original airing
many more us fans are now familiar with
the performance of Piccolo's original
Japanese actor toshio Furukawa
video
has a deep love and respect for Piccolo
and has no problem showing it he
explained in a Dragon Ball official site
interview whenever someone asks me who
my favorite character is I always answer
Piccolo without hesitation I have around
3 000 Piccolo figures if that gives you
an idea of how much I like him funnily
enough Piccolo becomes a collector of
sorts in the movie Dragon Ball super
superhero he amasses several panenko
plushies from Videl and Gohan despite
his protests even if Piccolo isn't as
wild about his collection as Furukawa is
of his Piccolo figures perhaps deep down
he shares his voice actor's hobby let's
be clear the first character to ever
boast a power level above 1 million is
Frieza The Intergalactic Tyrant shows
off his mic during his second
transformation on Namek against the Z
Fighters several other Dragon Ball
villains such as Majin Buu and Moro and
heroes like the Supreme Kai clearly
possess power levels exceeding 1 million
and they achieved it long before they
actually appear in the series the first
hero to surpass 1 million on screen is
Piccolo the namekian accomplishes this
feat in the Frieza Saga when he absorbs
the Namek Warrior nail the resulting
power boost is tremendous making Piccolo
more than a match for frieza's sophomore
state in the manga Piccolo's new
Strength leads Frieza to change into his
third form mere moments into their fight
however in the anime Frieza mistakenly
remains in his second form too long
allowing Piccolo time to show off his
full unrestrained power while Frieza
does easily regain the advantage when he
completes his transformation that
doesn't take away from Piccolo's
impressive Milestone achieving it before
even Goku long time readers and viewers
are used to seeing Goku in fights but
they know he's had his fair share of
defeats too when fighting in the World
Martial Arts Tournament he lost the
final round Twice first to master roshi
in Disguise in the 21st tournament then
to Tian shinhan in the 22nd
all right
that all changes in the 23rd tournament
which Piccolo enters to get his revenge
on Goku for killing his previous
Incarnation The Demon King Piccolo the
namekian proves to be Goku's match with
the Saiyan just barely defeating his
reborn foe but Piccolo shouldn't feel
too badly about the loss as it convinces
Goku to both spare his life and give him
the title of Arch Enemy as a sign of
respect but Piccolo's defeat by Goku in
the finals is unique since the Saiyan
abandons the next two World Martial Arts
tournaments he takes part in and gets
tickled out of a victory in Dragon Ball
GT
if somebody asks a Dragon Ball fan what
Piccolo's signature move is many would
likely say it's the special beam Cannon
the technique first appears in Dragon
Ball Z during the fight with Goku's
brother Radix though he first misses his
Target his second attempt is a direct
and lethal hit thanks to Goku's
sacrifice Piccolo's not too choked up as
he considered Goku an enemy at the time
the special beam cannon goes on to
appear many times in the anime and
movies often when Piccolo makes his
entrance but in the original Dragon Ball
Manga which isn't split into Dragon Ball
and Dragon Ball Z as it is in the U.S
Piccolo never uses it again after
defeating Raditz it's not until the
Dragon Ball super manga that Piccolo
uses the special beam Cannon again
though he had already used it a few
notable times in the super anime though
much of Akira toriyama's Dragon Ball
tends to be action-packed and dramatic
he's a comedy guy by his own admission
while his most famous work of humor is
Dr slump there are plenty of jokes and
gags throughout the Dragon Ball Saga he
often includes comical characters like
the fighting con man Hercule aka Mr
Satan among his favorite Dragon Ball
characters
[Music]
another of his preferred Creations is
Piccolo who's quite serious by
comparison why him quite simply because
he's a man of few words which creates a
sense of mystery that Toriyama likely
considers part of his appeal Toriyama is
also a big fan of Piccolo's dad noting
that Goku's fight with the demon king is
one of his favorite battles in Dragon
Ball for the most part the Dragon Ball
Dragon Ball Z and Dragon Ball super
anime are faithful to the character
designs from the manga as for Piccolo
his design differences are small but
still notable in the manga Piccolo like
the rest of his species has three
fingers and thumb while the anime throws
in one more the poor neglected pinky
while the anime series also changed the
color of Piccolo's scales from gold to
Pink the movie Dragon Ball super
superhero gives Piccolo's skills their
original manga color but he's kept that
extra finger faithful Dragon Ball Z
viewers will probably remember the grand
Kai besides being the boss of the other
four cardinal kais the grand Kai is
memorable for his laid-back almost
hippie-like demeanor his biggest role in
the anime is holding the other World
Tournament where he promises Goku a
training lesson for being a finalist
in his current condition I'm not sure
his uh
while the grand Kai has also appeared in
the Dragon Ball Z movies Dragon Ball GT
and even Dragon Ball Z Kai the final
chapters he doesn't show up in the
original manga at all it's easy to think
that like the grasshopper Gregory the
grand Kai is an anime only character but
leave it to Piccolo to confirm the
character does exist in the manga when
Piccolo forfeits his match with the
mysterious Shin who he believes to be
the grand Kai Shin corrects him
explaining he's actually the Supreme Kai
that scene which the anime adapts pretty
Faithfully proves that the grandkai
exists somewhere in the source materials
Universe perhaps one day the Dragon Ball
super manga will finally deal the grand
Kai in
they may come from different worlds but
Piccolo and Vegeta have a lot in common
there are aliens who live on earth both
aloof guarded and at times ruthless to
their enemies both begin as villains
when they're introduced only to later
reform you'd think with all their
similarities the two would be friends of
course Vegeta's pride and temper make it
difficult for him to become Pals with
anyone but the two have never fought
either despite having been enemies
during their first encounters when
Vegeta first arrives on Earth he lets
Napa fight Piccolo and his Earthling
allies with Piccolo being killed before
he even gets a chance to face the Saiyan
Prince on top of that after Vegeta's
reform the two have seemingly never even
sparred with each other while Vegeta may
consider Piccolo too weak to train with
it'd certainly be interesting to see if
he changed his mind now with Piccolo's
new orange form being a factor poor Goku
a lot of people have wanted him dead
over the years one of them is Piccolo
his beef began when the Saiyan first
interfered in the namekians Quest for
world domination Piccolo's hatred only
grew when Goku killed his Demon King
Incarnation and vanquished him at the
World Martial Arts Tournament oh
I really think this is gonna hurt
a lot
so what makes Piccolo different from
everyone else who's tried to send Goku
to the next Dimension two things he's
the first person to actually succeed
when his special beam Cannon kills
Raditz and Goku simultaneously the other
is even more surprising he's the only
heroic character to do the deed sure he
isn't a hero at the start of Dragon Ball
Z but he does become one not long
afterward not even other ex-villains
like Tian shinhan or Mr boo can say
they've done the same though in Boo's
case it's kind of a technicality as Goku
is already dead when they fight while
the character we know as Piccolo has
gone by that name for centuries it's not
the one given to him when he and Kami
were born so what was he called before
not even he knows as Mr Popo reveals the
namekian who eventually splits into Kami
and Piccolo arrived on earth when he was
incredibly young he ended up forgetting
everything about his alien Origins his
name included when the namekian
eventually decides to purge all evil
from himself the malevolent half takes
on the name Piccolo the word for another
world in his native language the other
half becomes known by his new title Kami
a Japanese word for God Piccolo and Kami
relearn their alien Origins when they
fuse back together yet most of their
memories from nemec their trip to Earth
and their original namekian name never
return he eventually decides to just
stick with Piccolo so Goku won't call
him kamikolo Vegeta isn't the only
Saiyan with whom Piccolo shares some
things in common like Goku Piccolo
travels to Earth to avoid becoming a
victim to a catastrophic event in Goku's
case it's the destruction of Planet
Vegeta making him one of the Lost
survivors of a species in piccolos it's
a Calamity that kills all but two people
on Namek who is Piccolo's fellow
Survivor why none other than Guru Frieza
and his wicked men because of them
nearly all my children have have been
murdered having become the sole
inhabitant of Namek after Piccolo's
departure Guru repopulates the planet
consequently Piccolo has become the only
namekian not descended from Guru well
there's also Lord Slug but seeing as the
movie Dragon Ball Z Lord Slug isn't
Canon he may not exist in the universe
at all as most Dragon Ball fans know
Goku is just a kid when his adventures
begin but even in his mid-teens Goku
doesn't really mature all that
noticeably it's not until his fight
Piccolo that Goku actually appears grown
up as it turns out Piccolo is actually
responsible for Goku's growth spurt
kazuhiko torishima the manga editor of
Dragon Ball and weakly Shonen Jump
claimed Toriyama had grown frustrated
with having to always fudge Goku's
height and other physical attributes to
make his battles with taller opponents
seem more believable since Piccolo is
both taller and less comical than most
of Goku's previous opponents Toriyama
felt depicting Goku with actual muscles
would not only make the fights look more
detailed and impactful but also more
realistic and dramatic so while Goku
still has the same kid proportions
against Demon King Piccolo he's
noticeably Changed by the time he fights
Piccolo Jr perhaps Goku's youngest son
Goten would have had his own growth
spurt earlier if he'd fought with
Piccolo more often
foreign